let's talk about this other story so uh
will brought this up to us before the
show i missed this one judge holds
washington dc jail officials in contempt
in a january 6 riot case basically they
say
that judge royce lamberth summoned the
jail officials as part of the criminal
case into christopher warrell a member
of the proud boys who had been charged
in the january 6 attack at the capitol
he'd been accused of attacking police
officers with pepper spray gel and
prosecutors have alleged he traveled to
washington and coordinated with proud
boys
it's clear to me the civil rights of the
defendant were violated by the d.c
department of corrections lambert said i
don't know if it's because he's a
january 6th defender or not
the judge ordered quincy booth the
director of the city's department of
corrections and wanda patton the warden
of dc jail to be held in contempt of
court while he did not impose any
sanctions or penalties the judge said he
was referring the matter to the justice
department to investigate whether the
civil rights of the inmates in the jail
are being violated this is big so this
is over what was it he had a surgery he
needed or something he had a broken
wrist that he got in may mr warrell
who's also did he get the did he get the
break in jail yes he got the break while
in custody um and
uh apparently and
it still apparently has not yet gotten
the necessary surgery um to do it you
know this is a very very basic thing we
expect from our jails
um and they're torturing these guys man
i mean
the the only you know the best
explanation the most charitable one is
just pure incompetence right like the dc
jail is just this bad for everybody
which is not exactly you know
heartwarming right either way you're
either intentionally making like these
people's lives miserable or yeah i know
the the dc defendants or the january 6
defense are kind of in their own
separate facility right now as my
understanding they were kept segregated
from the rest of the general population
and maybe that facility has its just
owned huge problems
well if you remember last year when this
story was developing i was even telling
people um
sorry this year
uh earlier this year at around february
i was i was you know bringing up this
conversation where there was already
reports of torture of people being put
in solitary confinement of people being
beat back then so to hear that some of
these people are still in solitary
confinement that they're being held in
their own unit i mean this definitely
seems overboard i mean solitary
confinement for
walking into a building i mean some of
the people did commit some crimes but
but even then when you compare it to
you know some of the crimes happening in
major urban areas now i mean there's
there's there's uh not much to compare
here or just i mean even the treatment
of the of the you know the
rioters the antifa rioters
um over the course of the past few years
i mean there was actually one case um
judge trevor mcfadden you know he was
giving a sense and somebody had plea
pled to misdemeanor and i think the you
know the the you know the government was
asking for three months in jail or
something like that and he gave them
like three months probation or in like
no jail time at all and basically said
like i don't think you guys are serious
you guys have not treated these the same
way as the other the defendants like
there is criminal activity here so
there's gonna be a punishment you pled
to a misdemeanor that's a crime but like
you guys are you're wildly overblowing
this with asking for you know serious
cars you know incarceration we got to be
real on part of it though is that the
left
has uh experience yeah and not just with
their tactics while they insurrect but
also also the legal apparatus so when uh
on on january 7 uh january it was
january of 2017
um 21st i think it was trump's
inauguration i was there uh luke you
were there yep we were running through
the streets and it's really funny what
happened was we were running and there
was this moment where luke and i made
two different choices
a row of police were forming and luke
just ran for it and i got pepper sprayed
very heavily for it because they were
spraying the pepper spray and i was like
i'm seeing the circle i'm like it's
either now or never i get out and i
decided to go into the stairwell of a
building unfortunately that's the
decision every other antifa made and the
cops immediately surrounded the whole
group
so this whole group of people which is
several hundred people ultimately after
like an hour i got released they said i
would have been arrested three times a
lot of people they don't know what
arrest means i wasn't i wasn't processed
or charged i was arrested but eventually
a supervisor came out showed him my
press pass he pulled me and some other
journalists up but all of those people
were charged and they were charged with
conspiracy because they couldn't prove
any one person was the person who was
setting things on fire who that torched
the limousine or threw bricks through
windows and so they said charge them all
with conspiracy which which doesn't fly
the state has to prove you as a person
did something wrong and they can't prove
simply by wearing a hoodie
this is the tactic and it's why they do
it yeah regardless regardless
when it came to january 6 even if people
were wearing masks otherwise they went
above and beyond to torture these people
in prison these antifa people spent it
was overnight in jail the next day they
walked out to thunderous applause of
people outside these are people who were
running through the streets setting
fires beating like like smashing windows
destroying property they torched a limo
that belonged to some immigrant who had
a small business
these people get a slap on the wrist and
and a lot of their charges were dropped
too i remember hearing a lot about their
charges the mainstream media was
actually talking about it how this was a
travesty of injustice how this was
political
prosecution and then i remember a lot of
people who were part of it got off but
you compare that to the story of thomas
caldwell he's a 66 year old navy and fbi
veteran and according to him he was
never inside of the capitol he never was
a part of oath keepers he never
committed any acts of violence against
the state that they but the state
charged him as an oathkeeper leader
saying that he led the charge organized
everything and put him in solitary
confinement for 49 days he was just able
to go out uh of solitary confinement
he's speaking out against this story
thomas caldwell he is raising money
because the legal fees he says is uh is
is exacerbating him and destroying his
livelihood and he's uh he's saying that
his farm is going to be taken away soon
so he's still facing some legal court
proceedings but hearing stories of this
66 year old guy who again is an fbi
veteran is a is an old uh navy uh
military member to hear this kind of
happened to me definitely
shows me a totally different picture uh
than what happened during the trump
inauguration and look at that woman who
they the feds raided her house in alaska
wrong person wrong person because
someone uh on the airlines they got in
she got an argument over a mask um on
one of the airlines and they snitched
and they called the fbi and um
fbi followed up on the story uh very
digital vigilantly or digilently yeah i
mean diligently
we get to a point with these
conversations where i'm just like
can we just pull like words out of a hat
to make headlines like if the subject is
the right gets censored the libertarian
the freedom the anti-war types are the
ones who get censored and the
establishment shills and the democrats
don't and the law enforcement is heavily
weighted against people who are in
support of freedom in opposition to the
establishment and antifa gets a free
pass and the proud boy's rotten prison
why why it's almost like do we even need
npr to tell us this is happening we
could just be like hey here's the news
guys
the january 6th defendants are being
tortured antivo's being let go moving on
i don't i don't need a source for that
because it just happens all the time
right
i mean you know our one i think as you
mentioned our side is very bad at crime
in no way that the left is not the left
is just much better at crime yeah they
are they you know i'm reminded of you
know charles barkley talking about jesse
smollett and being like america don't
commit crimes with checks well i want to
be like america don't don't enter the
capitol without a mask on
you know you're just
you're you're done that way but also
clearly there's just this enormous
double standard in the way they're
treated i'm reminded of like a gambin
and the state of exception sovereignness
hugh decides in the exception and it's
like
we have this world where
you know this is like the idea that we
have equal justice between different
political sides is a total fiction
um that what we're seeing is just is a
total joke and
even if republicans take back the house
they're not going to do anything they
won't impeach by they should they won't
he he should be impeached i mean he
could have been impeached the moment he
did that thing with the eviction
moratorium where he said i don't think
this is constitutional but i'm going to
do it anyway and the supreme court said
you can't do it and he goes yeah i'll do
it again
yeah and then it's like i know it's
probably going to be found
unconstitutional i just don't really
care and it'll it'll it'll last a couple
of months for it to go through the court
system and that's time that they won't
be evicted so that's fine like that's
impeachable you have a duty to take care
that the laws are faithfully executed so
if you knowingly violate the
constitution exhausting man it's
impeachable it's just but it's you know
they're
like they're so feckless and convincing
the democrats were already talking about
just putting republican political
operatives in jail people got to get
active in the primaries and the state
level
that's that's everything but i saw that
kevin mccarthy has like record
fundraising you know he's like 60
million or something in the first nine
months of the year and i'm just like why
like he's so uh they don't they're just
they're they're they're on the same team
as the democrats to show exactly this is
why when you brought up clapper i
thought that james clapper sitting in
front of congress testifying saying we
did not wittingly spy on the american
people blatant lie
and then they let them go they still
don't charge them with any kind of
perjury or anything it's beyond general
hayden who's a part of newsguard
literally said the same thing former cia
and nsa had said no we're not spying on
anyone it's beyond politics it's like
the administrative state is protecting
their own yeah but maybe but biden's
part of that maybe of course he's part
of that of course he is
it's that's it's a big club and you
ain't in it i don't think you can use
politics to to
defend against that i mean you you know
that's ultimately
there is a world where you can that the
administrative state is subordinate to
the white house and the white house a
white house that knew what they were
doing and was really like aggressive
with their use of power could really do
real damage to the administrative state
the trump white house was not that white
house it just what because they just
were they got they were real real
cautious
and weren't willing to you know do the
make the changes that needed to be made
obama you think he knew how but just was
co-opted or something or obama was part
of it like obama was the administrative
state's candidate that's a way to think
of biden biden is like you know biden is
team administrative state the entire
premise of like democrat presidents is
like we will get out of the way and let
the bureaucracy do their thing
right that's that's basically how they
operate like biden's not you know that's
so the idea that you have a democrat
president really do anything about the
administrative state are you kidding and
that's their base that's that's their
that's their whole
the whole premise of their electing in
the first place thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you